6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth. I had my first drive in an electric car yesterday, Neil. It was amazing.
Electric cars are great in theory, but who has the money to buy one?
It's true that electric vehicles or EVs, as they're also called, are expensive.
But in some parts of the world, the switch to electric vehicles has been a major success story
in the fight against climate change. And it's not just rich people switching to electric.
In India, poorer workers are embracing it too.
Yes, in India, it's the drivers of small vehicles like motorbikes,
mopeds, scooters and rickshaws, known as two and three wheelers who dominate the road.
And now, over half of these are electric. In this program, we'll be discussing the growing
role of electric vehicles in the fight against climate change. And as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well. Great. But first, I have a question for you, Neil.
In India, many different vehicles use the road, but which country's car market is the biggest?
Is it A, the US, B, China or C, Japan?
Well, I'll guess it's the US that has the world's largest automobile market.
Okay, Neil. I'll reveal the answer at the end of the program.
While electric vehicles score better than petrol or diesel cars in most environmental tests,
there is some debate about exactly how green they are. A lot depends on how the electricity is
generated in the first place. And in India, more than three quarters of the electricity used
continues to be generated by coal. Nevertheless, in India, the transition to green transport is
well underway. Here's Louise Rebay, head of the climate organisation C40 cities,
explaining the appeal of EVs to Greia Jackson for BBC World Service Program, the climate question.
What is it about two and three wheelers that serve peeling?
I think it can be summarized in one word and its convenience from an accessibility and affordability,
an efficiency point of view. And on that first point of accessibility, the state of public transport
is not as developed as it is in places like London or Singapore. There's no Metro lines or
or Fancy Bus Networks and two and three wheelers spread in response to the slack of sufficient
or high quality frequent public transport infrastructure.
Greia asks why electric vehicles are so appealing, so desirable and attractive.
There are several reasons behind EVs appeal, including convenience and affordability,
being cheap enough for people to buy.
In places without reliable public transport, electric scooters are filling the gap.
That's really needed because the massive increase of petrol cars in Delhi has created a toxic
and very serious health risk. Smog. Smog is air pollution caused by a mixture of smoke, chemicals
and especially car exhaust fumes. It makes the atmosphere difficult to breathe and very unhealthy.
What's more, because children are smaller and closer to car exhaust pipes,
smog affects them most. In winter, the air in Delhi gets so bad they have to close the schools,
sometimes for weeks. Here's Greia Jackson again, taking up the story for BBC World Services,
the climate question.
They're having to shut schools because the pollution is so bad. Gosh, that's hardly a solution,
what can be done about it? Well, for India, the solution partly lies in switching to
electric scooters and e-richshaws. By 2030, the government wants 30% of its vehicles on the road
to be electric and has put up 1.2 billion dollars to make that happen.
When Greia discusses schools shutting because of air pollution, she uses the word gosh.
An expression uses show a strong feeling of surprise or wonder.
Luckily, the Indian government is taking measures to improve Delhi's air quality,
largely through the switch to greener electric vehicles. The government has put up over 1 billion
dollars to make this happen. The Frazelberg put up money for something, means to provide the money
needed to pay for it. In this area, it seems India is leading the world, which reminds me of your
quiz question, Beth. That's right. I asked you which country has the world's largest automobile
market, and you said the US. Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid, Neil. In fact, it's now China
that tops the list, showing that when it comes to green transport, bigger isn't always better.
Right, it's time to recap the vocabulary we've learned in this program, starting with two wheeler,
a vehicle with two wheels, such as a bicycle, motorbike or mopage.
The adjective appealing means attractive, desirable or interesting.
Affordability refers to being cheap enough for people to buy, or in other words, inexpensive.
Smog is air pollution caused by smoke and car fumes, which makes the atmosphere unhealthy
and difficult to breathe. Gosh is an expression used to show a strong feeling of surprise or wonder.
And finally, if you put up the money for something, you provide the money needed to pay for it.
Once again, our six minutes are up, but remember to join us again next time for more
trending topics and useful vocabulary here at 6 Minute English. Goodbye for now. Bye.